all right rodney yes sir rodney uh
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally
california okay and tell me about how
you grew up you had both your parents as
a kid um well maybe in the beginning but
i don't remember much of that um
my dad left and then uh
my my mom was an alcoholic so maybe
that's why he left and i'm not sure we
took her talk about that
when did your dad leave how was you like
maybe three years since i got two or
three
and uh we never really talked about mom
me didn't really talk about it you know
i suppose my dad you know don't worry
about it you know stuff like that
um because she's an alcoholic and she
didn't really just come and shut up
he'll go go go away go in my room go do
something you know go play on a freeway
you know pretty much yeah um were you an
only child
yeah
yeah
so
i just kind of stayed around and you
know tried to be with my mom a little
bit just because that's the only thing i
knew you know and i thought that was
kind of the normal way to grow up is to
be
alone you know told to shut up go your
room and you know don't bother me
food was kind of scarce you know not all
not always dinner or nothing like that
um
or if it was it was really something
thrown together you know
um
and then i found out later
you know well
at that time it still was it still was
good just eating slop and just stuff
thrown together not not every day not
all the time
um so you just tell me something like
well we don't have any money for for
food today you know don't worry you know
we'll be okay and i'll go okay okay you
know and i go home hungry you know go to
bed hungry just like this normal normal
thing for everybody they don't really
talk to nobody at the time
um so then later on
i started you know
meeting other kids and she didn't like
that too much so it kind of pulled me
out of school you know told me to stay
home and she'll teach me you know she
can teach me nothing you know
but um
tell me how to drink maybe you know
she's about six or five or six
i started grabbing her she'd walk off
and i'd grab her drink you know a couple
swigs of it
or or even once later on the whole thing
you know but she would never notice you
know
put water in the booze and take the
booze out and put water in and
still she didn't notice you know i guess
she was pretty pretty um pretty dawn you
know
how freshman school i'm sorry how far
did you go in school well in the
beginning they're not not much but um at
the end it all went to 10th grade
that um i didn't mention bad boy classes
and stuff like that special eds and
stuff like that do one paper and stuff
like that and during school
would you like to go after that
um
well
well
i like
13 13 or something like that i started
having blackouts
so i couldn't really remember much of
the day
once once a day got started
i was pretty much drunk from the night
before you know so once i had those
couple more drinks in the morning
my day was just like
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened and
excuse me i started giving my language
but um yeah i didn't understand anything
that was going on people tell me the
next day what'd you do this for you
what are you talking about you know
and i didn't remember you know so i said
i just played it off like i didn't
remember or you know getting crazy to
blow it off you know but it didn't
really work out too good and then um and
that's why i started the bad boy classes
you know i just told them i don't
understand what's going on there people
are accusing me of this and accusing me
of that and
they're full of it you know so they
would tell me okay you know just do your
little paperwork and
carry on
um
back to back to backing up a little bit
off my funk's third grade they had some
beer in my my show-and-tell box
i don't know
not a beer but a little bottle of
whiskey you know
and um it's what it is like oh i don't
know when who's that
mom's maybe you know she wants to stash
it in here you know okay and then they
talked to the principal and then
expelled me you know said to take third
grade over
that didn't go over well either with me
you know
this whole thing was just kind of
troublesome you know because of my mom i
did she raised me to think that this is
all norm and then i come to find out
that it's not you know so it kind of
kept through me for a loop you know um
maybe it had something to do with me
being here now i don't know
um you know
shortly after having all the blackouts
and stuff i ended up
doing some bad stuff you know and um
ended up in jail you know
been in jail most of my life because of
that
but i would get out and i'd be i think
i'm okay and i could drink again well
as soon as i started drinking again i
was back to the same you know how they i
don't know if you've ever been to aaa
they said it gets worse it gets worse
when you start again you start over
again where you were before you know
after a short period of time
and that's true you know that's what
happened to me
what what kind of offenses
god burglary damn vagary
um
it doesn't cause my stroke
i'm burglary guns discharging guns and
city limits
concealed weapons
um
fighting of course uh
under the influence a lot i'm not i'm
not really funny but the lady in the in
the twin towers figures what is it 11
550 b
i said it's under the influence why
it's good you know i have one you have
36 of those
and i kind of laughed at the time you
know because it's just funny you got 90
days and you get the 45 of them each
time you know and then burglaries again
um
criminal threats you know
um he's all
alcohol driven
yeah people pushing me pushing my
buttons
you know then i'd lash out you know
until i kill you man got the [ __ ] away
from me i'll kill your [ __ ] ass you
know as soon as you turn your back i'll
stab you in the [ __ ] neck you know
and they call a cop say something and
damn
i've been six years
probably 80 percent
four times
you know that's four years ten months
each time
but um since 91 i've pretty much been in
prison
and i haven't been out here much um but
every time i do
and do i get to this
because the only thing i know
you know my body's craving it even
though after four years it's still i you
know drank a lot of pruning though in
there that's probably why
but um
yeah i just
just gotta keep it going and if i don't
i know the sickness i'm gonna have just
like i had in there
and it's not worth it to me you know
how how was it going to prison or jail
with without the alcohol how was it yeah
did you did they make you go cold turkey
oh yeah oh god yeah i was shaking and
they give you something to give you a
pill but it didn't do anything to you
you know you just sit there and shake
and
ask people to give and give me your
sweets and stuff like that same as like
heroin now now they do i didn't know
that then but now i noticed that they do
the same thing they do with heroin the
same thing i want their sweets because
they give me sugar and people just i
don't know what it does to you but it
does something about the alcohol it
helps you out but um i'd go about
maybe a month and a half
sometimes too without without no alcohol
and they're just going nuts then like i
think i figured um
i uh
tweaked my brain a little bit by doing
that you know um like they say wet brain
whatever
um i have subrose to deliver about
17. um
but the biggest part was the um
kicking in in the county jail
and which made everybody leave me alone
in the beginning but later on they
didn't
once i'd come out of that then i'd be in
the fights and everything because i you
know
they start saying stupid stuff you know
and i just couldn't handle that you know
and i started really young just um why
are you talking to me like that i don't
know you you know
what it can be okay we can be friends
got a white boy you know about yeah i
get along with black great man you know
but
you know they're on me for some reason
um
do you have children of your own no do
you have kids no
i wanted to
i had one tubular pregnancy
with a girlfriend nobody
once said once at that first one
then i started thinking you know wait a
minute man you don't you don't the kids
don't deserve you you know the kids
understand to be raised by you or even
to be thought of by by you so
pretty much stops seeing anybody you
know you ever been in love yeah i've
been in love with a few times
but i never i never pursued it
you know because it's like am i gonna
proceed something that i can't can't
take care of you yeah you've been my
whole life [ __ ] up man you've been
drinking pretty much your whole life
yeah the big
breaks the breaks in jail yeah
even in jail i dreamed right yeah
we can prune them and don't know how to
make the bruno now you know
but yeah this is you know
they said touchy substitutes hit red
but yeah i've been in love a lot of time
and love down here man but i i want to
approach it
where are you staying now you see a few
different places wherever i can
you know i push the damn sickle right
there until somebody takes it they bite
guys take it and just crash wherever you
can yeah
sleep wherever i can where do you
how do you make money
sometimes you know i'm just pretty much
just asking money you know
it doesn't cause um doesn't always work
that well anymore because of a
pandemic you screwed me up um i had a
couple strokes out here we did twice
how old are you
no 61.
yeah 61 two strokes in
congestive heart failure
um
i think it's all to do with alcohol
pretty much
you probably would see that your life
took the the turns that it did because
of alcohol right guaranteed alcohol
drove your life
yeah yeah
and i can't stop it even as a young
child even in young time
they thought it was like i said man you
know i see my mom and she explained to
me this is the way it is you know i'm
like this because that's the way it is
it makes it
makes my life tolerable and you know and
i can raise you without your dad
you know your dad was this and that you
should say
why do you say that and she's just true
well i come to find out my dad was good
and he was not a piece of [ __ ] you know
but he didn't want me around not after
being with my mom that long
and you've been homeless for how long
do four years now maybe maybe almost
five
yeah did you hit jobs
have you had jobs
no no
it's really uh
really something that you to try and
even just to talk to people right to try
to talk to you even it's a little hard
you know
you don't really talk to that many
people
do you have friends no not really a
couple
couples then they try and do something
and
and i just you know i've had you know
through the times they've had a couple
but man they just they always want this
so they want that and they came out and
have nothing like that and they go
like
do you have a driver's license and you
know they always try to work something
out of you especially when they found
out you know i'm drink drunk after damn
time and
they think i don't remember everything i
don't but
but i remember them you know and it's
it's uh
it's a hard thing dude it's a hard thing
to have people want to you always want
to get your license and your social
security
and try and you know do things like that
and i guess i go for it sometimes when
i'm drunk you know
what is the what is the lowest point of
your what's been the lowest point of
your life
down here
today
no no down here
living down here listen i could be with
my mom my mom's dad now
she wants to deliver she died from that
but
i don't even know [ __ ] who my dad is you
know
but um
i don't know
i don't i really can't honestly say once
my lowest point in my life i'm
maybe didn't know if i if i look back
i would say being there with my mom you
know
why do i have to get raised like that
and it turned out like this you know
do i blame her no you know but do i yeah
you know i don't but i do
you know i mean
i can only think that she did the best
she could you
it's know little [ __ ] to think about
that man how could this lady
want to have this kid around you can't
even take care of you know the [ __ ]
throw me to somebody let me go
wherever the [ __ ] i was supposed to go
or whatever man let me go to my dad you
know
but
what emotions do you go through now
sadness man a lot bro are you angry as
well
man am i angry
saying i
just [ __ ] up bro you know
she's all kicked in you know
they can hit me as mother's day mine
making him bother me a bit and i just
get up what the [ __ ] that for you know
and here they come again you know
there's a couple more guys you know
you can't do it by yourself you know you
remind me of jail you know because the
south side is trying to attack you just
1000 attacks you think all of them come
after you you know and now now it seems
like the some of them some of the tough
black guys out here will do that same
touch tough black guys will attack you
by themselves but
most of them [ __ ] ones they'll get
their buddies and all that you know the
whistle and you know
[ __ ] they do
go ahead man you don't give a [ __ ] what
you gonna do man what do you think
that's all about is it racism or is it
it's not about racism it's about it's
about
them being their little gangs and this
and that you know because you can't but
why are they taking out an alcoholic is
on the street i don't think they know
i don't think they know it then why
would they be picking on you in the
first place
i'm thinking of me and my money maybe i
don't know
i'm always by myself you know say hey
come here white boy you know what what's
up you know stop what's up man
how you doing
rodney yeah and then you're like getting
money man and they get i don't have any
money let me see let me see your pockets
you
touch my pockets dude even if i'm not a
penny
you know you're not gonna touch my
[ __ ] problem what the [ __ ] wrong
with you man you know you're some [ __ ]
you know you're not gonna do that to me
and then here we go and it starts you
know
and i should just shut up maybe i should
just shut up and let him do it but
this that drives me the wrong way man
how are you feeling somebody asked you
that you know
it's hard man i'm [ __ ] up man how much
do you drink
i like
if i can't if i have enough money maybe
four or five
functions
eight of these a day at least
at least no more what does your typical
day look like you wake up and
wake up
go get a beer
for sure
and then
you'll start maybe just asking for money
gotta get some more beer
some cigarettes
and then just
just try and
think about this [ __ ] how to get out
of this you know
my first couple beers would take me
there
almost almost every day you know
um
but i can't remember that much stuff
because of my stroke
double strokes and then
it's like um
i gotta i gotta you know bring it back
you know each time i have to bring it
back to where i was wrong man i said i
said this [ __ ] yesterday you know
and tried to remember that stuff it's
just one from my alcoholism dude [ __ ]
me up uh i can't remember a lot another
stroke thing
he said my speech gets messed up and
i feel like i'm slurring and all this
and now like
i'm trying not to say that to you right
now because i feel that's what i feel
like i'm doing but um i'm
trying not to um
i can look at your shirt and go
it's your shirt tonight soon i can't
[ __ ] say blue you know whatever i
just can't say it you know i can
whatever it is i'm looking at i can't
say what i'm and you can look at it and
say i say something that's a hundred
times pretty much a result from your
stroke yeah and i can't say what the
[ __ ] i'm trying to say
you know it's terrible
um
but
you know it's it's it's going all right
i guess you know
this this is just this is gonna help me
a lot right here you know i can finally
get some shoes and
some medication into my leg
my legs all screwed up man
you see you start talking away over here
and get it down
yep
and then all the way up here
and started to come up to here really
see the spot right here yeah that's
what's happening this infection is going
going up my leg
because they can't afford to body
medicine you know
i can't take penicillin or that not
normal next moccasin
all right so i take this other stuff and
the nurse the nurse taught me that i'm
not the nurse that the pharmacy lady
helped me she trained uh
you didn't have a phone like you know
that right now you know
she said get our ex she put me in her
phone he had to contact and then put me
get rx and split my medicine in half you
know
i still can't get the money you know
just
[ __ ] up just to drink it
to drink it's not to drink is
not gonna happen
i'm not gonna start stop that [ __ ] you
know to have to have myself go through
all the tremors and all this stuff out
here
you know i can't do that you know i'd
rather they cut my leg off rather than
me stop drinking and what every morning
every day you know what i mean
you know it's [ __ ] dismissable to be
having not have a then i have a drink
and then
you could be more miserable without my
leg but
before the pandemic i was fine man i
get a lot of money and everything now
people only want to look at you man you
know
what's your biggest regret right i'm
sorry what's your biggest regret
the pandemic
the biggest regret is this pandemic [ __ ]
man
yeah i say i can't get any money like i
used to enjoy
to think like to think uh
yeah i'm just gonna make sure i have a
bill rather than
worry about my legs you know
but it's like you take 25 bucks for the
medicine for this you know he was 55
with the lady cut it in half and then
i told her i said i can't get that money
man i just can't do it and she says why
because i have to i gotta have this you
know i pulled my bottle out of my i had
a bottle of time
pulled my bottle and i
i'd rather lose my leg and to have to
stop you know
to go through the misery every day of
losing that you know i'd rather not have
a leg and just they'd go through that
misery you know to be
just you know just it's just a drag man
you know
it's part of the reason i'm here today
is to try and get enough money to maybe
to get that you know
you said that much touch recycling is
expensive though you know and have to do
30 days 30 days to get rid of it
and you know a long time ago i had any
sections like that
but
just i don't know it's just
anything that changed my life managed
something god had come in or devil to
come in or whatever
somebody you know
but um
thank you for your time too man yeah so
thank you rodney i actually like to see
this in video you know and media on
youtube yeah
you